I'm Jordy Nelson, and this is "Build Your Squad."
All right, so my first pick, man...
is the foundation of the team with the quarterbacks.
Aaron's not up there, so it makes it a little difficult. That'd been the easy No. 1 pick.
You see Favre, another Packer.
Since we're here at Super Bowl LIV, Chiefs-49ers,
let's go with—they're callin' it the Montana Bowl, right?
Ya know, since he played for both. Grew up watchin' Joe when he came over
and played with the Chiefs, so,
put Joe Montana out there.
The running back's easy for me.
Some guy who can do it all,
another Kansan—a lotta people don't realize it, but another Kansan.
You gotta go with Barry Sanders.
Grew up in Wichita, Kansas. I grew up in Kansas. So we gotta stick together.
As receivers...
man.
This is gonna be—this is tough.
We'll stick with receivers. We'll leave the tight end out. We'll go with Jerry Rice.
Kind of a given. Um, he's got all the numbers.
Did it for years and years and years, so,
uh, we'll put him up there, and you gotta keep the chemistry goin'.
You don't wanna mess up the chemistry.
I know a lot about—I had a lot of chemistry with my quarterbacks, so,
you gotta keep the chemistry.
DBs.
I loved Ed Reed.
Just a playmaker, all over the place. Uh, can do it all, leader on a team.
Played with an incredible defense.
And someone...
we'll go Reggie White to get after the quarterback.
Put another—get a Packer guy in there. I know he's in an Eagles uniform but,
um, kinda changed the Packer organization.
Put 'em back on the map with the Super Bowl, with him and Brett comin' in, so.
There you go, there's my squad. I don't think you can argue with it.
Obviously, talk about the quarterback; it was difficult. Obviously, these guys are all great.
Winners. Productive. Everything.
I would've thrown 12 in there for my, for my sake.
Running backs is easy for me just with Barry.
The pass-catchers is tough.
I mean, you got Randy, who had a long career and did it in multiple spots
and did it at an elite level, especially early on too, and then came back with New England.
Tony Gonzalez is probably one of the most steady guys out there,
so that was tough not to, not to pick him. But you gotta—I had to go with a receiver, so.
In the DB world, Deion is the guy, but I wanted to go with a safety,
with Ed and all the playmaking he did, but
Deion would've—shoot, I coulda had Deion play receiver and DB and return punts.
So, probably shoulda done that. Coulda gotten more out of one guy.
And then Reggie was a given, so, we'll go with that one.
All right, so this is my squad right here.
We got Joe Montana throwin' to his guy Jerry Rice,
who's gonna be open all the time cuz they're worried about Barry Sanders runnin' the ball.
And then we have the stoppers on defense,
the guy gettin' after the quarterback and the guy pickin' off all the passes.
So, this is my squad.
On behalf of Michelob Ultra Pure Gold,
the organic beer changing regular farms into organic farms.